und wir wollen jetzt weiter sprechen
über die situation mit christian mölling
erst direktor des forschungsinstituts
der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik kurz d gap einen
schönen guten morgen guten morgen der
russische präsident putin schlägt mit
seiner entscheidung im grunde ja jetzt
alle verhandlungs türen zu womit rechnen
sie
also ich gehe davon aus dass als
nächstes eine antwort aus dem westen
kommt wir haben jetzt in der nacht schon
gesehen dass die usa entsprechendes
vorbereiten und so dass man ganz klar
auf diese situation einfach reagieren
muss weil man jetzt nicht lange warten
kann weil man sonst schwach da steht
auch in den augen putins ich glaube das
wird wahrscheinlich das erste sein was
kommt es ist bereits abgelehnt worden
diese sogenannte unabhängigkeit auch da
muss man sagen diese region mögen alles
sein aber sie sind definitiv jetzt nicht
mehr unabhängig sondern sie sind jetzt
nur noch abhängig von moskau ich glaube
das ist der der entscheidende punkte
dieser situation putin schafft er jetzt
knallharte fakten der amerikanische
präsident biden hat aber ausgeschlossen
dass amerikanische soldaten
in der ukraine zum einsatz kommen
glauben sie dass das noch wackeln könnte
in den nächsten tagen und wochen und
dann das glaube ich nicht also erstens
haben wir keine kriegssituation in der
ukraine wir haben zwar eine okkupation
der ost ukraine durch russische
streitkräfte die offensichtlich ist
jetzt oder in zukunft kommen wird das
ist damit auch eine militärische
eskalation aber es gibt keinen
militärischen einsatz in dem sinne dass
es ein 1 schieß krieg an der an der
ostukrainischen grenze an der an der
kontakt linie zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
gibt
zweitens hat die usa und haben auch die
nato klar gemacht dass sie nicht kommen
werden um die ukraine zu verteidigen im
rahmen von irgendwelchen schutzabkommen
da ist sozusagen die die rote linie die
die usa auf alle fälle einhalten werden
weil beiden auch weiß dass dieses
engagement bei sich zu hause zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt hoch umstritten ist
hermeling pro-russische separatisten
besetzen ja nur einen teil der beiden
donbass provinz hat auch gerade unsere
korrespondentin einer weiß gesagt also
lohans und dann jetzt den anderen
kontrolliert die op die ami wird putin
das jetzt militärisch ändern und die
gesamte region unter russische kontrolle
bringen wollen ja ich glaube die
vergangenheit hat gezeigt dass
spekulationen über die interessen des
präsidenten zwar angebracht sind aber
niemals beantwortet werden können ich
glaube was wir vor allen dingen sehen
können ist dass putin einen weiteren zug
machte ihm alle optionen offen lässt
sowohl jetzt sozusagen in kleinen
schritten die die grenze noch weiter
nach westen zu verschieben der der
besetzten gebiete als auch weiterhin
noch die möglichkeit sich offen hält
einer größeren version dafür spricht in
der vergangenheit zwar nichts russe hat
nie große invasion gemacht das heißt
aber nicht dass wir hier nicht auch
sozusagen eine eine neuerung sehen
könnten ich glaube das wird vor allen
dingen sagen muss dass die idee wer
verhandelt schießt nicht in dem sinne
nicht funktioniert also russland macht
beides ist verhandelt ich glaube auch
dass russland an den verhandlungstisch
zurück kommt aber substanzielle
ergebnisse als in der vergangenheit
nicht gegeben wir können vielleicht noch
mal einen blick auf die rede die sehr
umfangreiche rede von putin werfen die
er gestern gehalten hat er der ukraine
die souveränität abgesprochen er
kündigte außerdem an russische
streitkräfte sollen in den gebieten den
frieden sichern und er warf kiew
außerdem vor in der ost ukraine einen
genozid an der russischen bevölkerung zu
begehen das ist auch völliger quatsch
ja aber er muss seine legitimation
schaffen für das nach innen hingegen
zieht es den legitimation die der westen
im kosovo krieg benutzt hat also alles
das dinge die möglicherweise auch
reminiszenzen für die für die
vergangenheit sind ist es neu feminismus
das was da jetzt passiert
friedenstruppen zu nennen aber alles das
sind im grunde genommen ja rhetorischen
die die auch für den für den westen so
zusagen gemacht sind ich glaube den
fehler den wir jetzt machen können ist
dieses diese sachen einfach zu
übernehmen das sind okkupationstruppen
und keine friedenstruppen sonst geraten
wir irgendwann in eine in eine orange
sprachwelt in die wir nicht gehören ich
glaube wir müssen weiterhin dabei
bleiben sehr klar zu benennen was da
passiert es ist eine politische
eskalation die passiert und dass eine
militärische eskalation die passiert
darauf muss der westen eine klare
antwort finden weil ansonsten verliert
er das was den westen ausmacht nicht in
der ukraine sondern insgesamt für ganz
europa nehmen regeln nach denen
sicherheit und frieden in europa
funktionieren jetzt verschiebt putin
eigenmächtig innerhalb weniger jahre zum
zweiten mal grenzen in der ukraine
und es ist ein bisschen untergegangen
russland hat er quasi schon ein land
übernommen ohne dass sein einziger
schuss gefallen ist nämlich belarus wie
muss man diese strategie lesen
vor allem als nur sagen sehr guten
opportunismus oder ein gutes taktisches
spiel es war möglich das zu machen die
während der westen hat sich insgesamt
auf die ukraine konzentriert hat nicht
gemerkt was sonst noch passiert ist wir
sind tatsächlich zeit fixiert wenn sie
jetzt mal sozusagen den fokus auf machen
dann haben wir auf der anderen seite
china dass hinter dieser hinter dieser
aufmerksamkeit wand im grünen genommen
zurzeit relativ einfach agieren kann wir
haben auch schwere aktivitäten oder
sozusagen wichtige entscheidungen die
getroffen mit blick auf das iranische
atomprogramm wir gucken zurzeit im
wesentlichen auf die ukraine und mögen
dabei das große ganze
möglicherweise aus dem aus dem blick
verlieren wir dürfen sicher sein moskau
und peking tun das nicht das ist glaube
ich der wichtige punkt zu sehen wir
haben viele unterschiedliche spieler die
hier gerade gespielt werden es ist nicht
alleine die ost ukraine um die es geht
um es geht letztendlich hier um die
sicherheit europa ist und die frage wie
das in zukunft sein wird hängt im
wesentlichen davon ab wie wir jetzt auf
diese weiteren provokationen reagieren
und das wird uns noch lange zeit
beschäftigen danke für diese
einschätzung heute morgen das war
christian mölling direktor des
forschungsinstituts der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
dankeschön ich danke ihnen